das beste veganer restaurant der welt
veganismus und vegane lebensmittel sind
unweigerlich einer der größten trends in
der food welt der letzten jahr es war
nur eine frage der zeit bis auch in der
gehobenen küche in der krisen in der
sternegastronomie veganes kochen einzug
hält dementsprechend habe ich wirklich
das gefühl im heutigen video eine sache
zu erleben die ich wahrscheinlich ganz
ganz lange nicht vergessen werden kann
und auch eine sache die wegweisend sein
könnte für das fine dining der zukunft
wir sind nach luxemburg gefahren und das
mit einem stern bewertete la distillery
zu testen welches von einem unfassbar
engagierte sternekoch geführt wird der
auf den tischen ein einseitiges erklärt
schreibe über seine motivation und die
bedeutung dieser veganen küche für sich
selbst erläutert als wir ankamen hatte
ich noch nicht den blassesten schimmer
was mich wirklich erwarten würde die
haben nur festgestellt wie wunderschön
das setting von restaurants also ich
glaube das ist wahrscheinlich das
schönste setting von einem restaurant
das ich bisher gesehen habe das
restaurant ist nicht nur in dieser
friedvollen grünen umgebung sondern es
ist in diesem schloss dass man nicht
sehen kann man dann eine hecke
[Musik]
wir kommen rein das ist keine tischdeko
dessen haselnuss
süßkartoffel und verschiedene andere
blätter das können wir besser schmecken
ich glaube sei bei wir müssen uns vor
augen halten wir sind hier im besten
blicke an ist aus der welt der rosen
ich habe das gefühl das spiel direkt ein
bisschen mit dem klischee dass veganer
nur blätter aber dass er für diese
stupide klischee mit dem wir heute wenn
wir irgendwo damit aufräumen können dann
hier heute hier sehen wir exzellente
kochkunst und das ganze in einem veganen
rahmen nicht nur bekannt sondern auch
glutenfrei also ich bin mehr als
gespannt was hört erwarten dürfen und
ich nehme jetzt das erste blatt deshalb
mit irgendwas überzogen und ditte das in
dieses soße die wir haben probiert mal
und bin gespannt ob man bis man
schmecken glauben geworden
richtig gut schon wie das häufig in der
sterneküche ist wurden wir erst mal
vollkommen über man von den ganzen
eindrücken und während wir dann diese
wirklich leckeren blätter gegessen haben
kamen dann auch schon die ersten gänge
ausdrücklich zu wir haben hier ein grund
um das ok aufgebrachten tapioka mit
aktivkohle direkt kühlt textur alles wie
gehabt und ich alles am start bis jetzt
von der raffinesse steht das unseren
bisherigen sterne restaurant in keinem
fall überhaupt gar keinen fall
das geht so aber verstehen
rosenwasser und warum man dann kommt die
drei dinge als zweiter dann kommen noch
was und dann wusste man spätestens jetzt
merkte es wahrscheinlich das ist mal
wieder so ein restaurantbesuch aus der
kategorie mehr als zehn gänge
dementsprechend nimmt es mir nicht übel
dass ich nicht differenziert auf alles
eingehen kann ich werde mein bestes tun
ein grundgefühl zu vermitteln was dieser
abend bei mir erzeugt probieren wir
jetzt mal diese geschichte hier
das heißt auch tat weil es so wenige
gedanken von dem tatort bleibt man hat
gelbe was so ein bisschen aussieht wie
vor ist das lecker aber ich mag nicht
voran hoffe ich so einen erfüllenden
gegangen heute es einen erfüllenden gang
klingt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
komisch für diejenigen unter euch die
einen veganen lebensstil leben aber ich
sehe das ganze durch eine am niveau
brille also als ein mensch der alles ist
und da gibt es halt manche gerichte die
so eine tiefe befriedigung bei einem
auslösen wenn man einfach so sagt da
könnte ich mich jetzt rein legen und das
erste was mir im kopf kommt ist ein
steak sind bürger solche geschichten ich
glaube ihr wisst was ist jetzt das
dritte mal dass uns eine vielzahl von
startern gebracht wurde der mir einmal
eingerichtet welches einfach noch
fenchel heißt dann haben wir halt
irgendwas gebacken und galloways umflut
gazpacho also ich probiere das hier erst
mal war das motto heißt aufgepasst
[Musik]
das hat richtig an aber das ist lecker
oder angegossen da waren so verpuffte
reißen dann sage ich aber mein und sie
sind jetzt wieder wir haben die soße
aufgezogen und schmecken einfach so
richtig kräftig und vollmond liegt diese
fenchel note ist gar nicht mal so
präsent die geschmackliche vielfalt ist
schon verrückt dass heute eine kleine
abkühlung können wir das gut gazpacho
es wurde einfach einmal komplett andere
innere von geschmacks spektrum geschickt
von herzhaft heiß zu kühl frisch
bisschen säuren
man hat das gefühl man ist dass gutes
und fühlt sich ganz gut ist wir haben
jetzt ein griff das trägt den namen
bundeswehr grünes gemüse
dementiert dass angebote früchte und
chili und gespannt wie das ganze
schmeckt ist es wieder zu schön zum
anschauen er hat einfach selbst noch so
letter darauf drapiert mail wie sieht
aus wie summe vogelbeere gleich bin ich
aber tod zum herbst hin einfach
[Musik]
für mich ist das einfach noch viel
kreativer als das man sonst in der
sterneküche erlebt dabei das spielfeld
so viel kleiner ist ich habe das gefühl
in der guten küche gibt es auch gut und
die prinzessin bari heißen kaviar die
heißen dass drei oder wie auch immer
halt irgendwelche richtiggehende teuren
tierischen produkte die durch ihre natur
ganz viel gespannt wenn sich bringen und
diesen ziel kommen können sich die küche
hier nicht kann man es irgendwie
beschreiben weil ich glaube nicht aber
das ist problem auch das wird häufiger
treffen werden das wird sehr schwer
alles zu erklären man hat wirklich
gemerkt wie wichtig dem sternekoch rené
matte die erfahrung der gäste ist durch
dinge wie das erklärt schreiben aber
auch dadurch dass er wirklich jeden
einzelnen gang persönlich präsentiert
und erklärt hat diese begeisterung
schmeckt man einfach und es ging sogar
so weit dass er am tisch die finalen
vorbereitung noch getroffen hat
höchstpersönlich
pathetischen wieder also die strotzen
hier wirklich nur von vier das so verrät
was er bekommen alles was wir wissen hat
mit tomate zu können
[Musik]
ich dachte zuerst der punkt dass in ein
öl- oder karamell tomate und karamell
punkt wird eine mythen gewürz mich schon
gedreht das ist schon wieder so ein hund
gefühlen zum text oder kennst das
einfach nicht es ist einfach so foto
figge macht aus dieser
sehr sehr lecker die gerösteten kerne
haben so einen chronischen das ist nicht
besonders sexy
die man schmeckt einfach und automatisch
leute wir sind jetzt durch die halbe
karte durch und ich fühle mich ein
bisschen so als hätte ich das allererste
mal noch mal ein sterne restaurant
besuchen fehlen wirklich einfach die
worte wenn ich die verschiedenen
gerichte probieren weil alles so neu und
außergewöhnlich ist sondern dass man
irgendwie so ein bisschen halt sucht um
sich zu orientieren
dabei so beschreiben was man schmeckt
das ist eigentlich das was man erlebt
haben
geht es genauso wir sitzen beisammen
was schmeckt so aber es schmeckt alles
sehr sehr gut und ich tue mein bestes um
sich zu erklären was ist gut mal rein
optisch habt ihr schon gesehen das ist
einfach konstruiert was hier auf den
tisch gezogen ich fand es wirklich sehr
inspirierend ihm dabei zuzusehen und
mitzuerleben wie passionierte er einfach
mit der ganzen sache ist also ich habe
schon einige solcher begegnungen gehabt
der betreiber vom besten bilder laden
der beste pizza bäcker der welt diese
tiefe überzeugung sieht man wirklich nur
bei den besten der welt unser nächster
gang wird auf einem blatt von der
pflanze die uns gerade präsentiert wurde
serviert das hier unten ist nicht gebaut
weil irgendwas einmal ein frittiertes in
so einer art teig gehörtes
herum drauf haben wir
fermentierte sonnenhut dass jeder eine
weitere kreationen die man so oder so
ähnlich noch nie gegessen hat ganz genau
hier haben wir jetzt erstmalig so was
wie so ein anhaltspunkt schmecken müssen
wir krabbeln schluss ohne diesen meeres
geschmack aber
herzhaft vollmundig ganz verrückt extra
man ist wieder so um nach denkt man es
voller name natürlich sehr sehr und das
ist richtig erkannt wenn man sich allein
die hände anschaut so gefällt mir
richtig gut
[Musik]
das hier gut fotografieren kann man
sofort an die wand hängen
bild das sich und kommt locker aus dem
handgelenk so am tisch das ganze duftet
er hat gesehen dass wurde ein geräusch 1
zucchini ist der star der show bei
diesen gerichten probleme machen
[Musik]
es ist einfach so viel mehr als diese
die basis ist es so viel mehr braucht
als die zucchini racer sekte heftig
wünscht dadurch dass die sorten
geräuchert wurde so sieht das ganz
wunderbar weich innen drin bist du noch
mal quasi lackiert mit was auch immer
für einen zauber kraut auf jeden fall
schmeckt es wirklich nicht wie von nrw
jetzt mal festhalten muss auch als alles
es mit den jetzigen zeitpunkt kann ich
steht diese restaurantbesuch in seiner
qualität also auch sternen geboten
anderen restaurants überhaupt nicht mehr
glaube wir kommen als nächstes zum
letzten herzhaften fünf stück insgesamt
langsam
und auch so ein bisschen gesenkt
[Musik]
ich glaube wir sind beim highlight bei
wieder bildhübsch wunderschön darsteller
wir haben eine bis die creme denn das
ganze heißt artischocken
scheinbar zur familie der artischocken
und wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal alles
wieder kurz gedacht auf eine gabel und
probieren
bringen gut ist dass
und dann war er endlich da der gang gehe
ich die ganze zeit erwartet und erhofft
habe die herzhaft ich kite die textur in
dem moment wo ich das ganze gegessen
habe ich wirklich überhaupt nichts mehr
vermisst du kannst mir nicht erzählen
dass er keine tierischen produkte sein
sondern weil das schmecken sind kein
arancino haben sich selbst genannt du
kannst mir nicht erzählen dass da nicht
irgendwie
echt jetzt ich bin wirklich traurig dass
es nicht so viele dass das ist so lecker
dass auch viel davon essen werden herbst
überlegt was diestelkamp und schmeckt
weil sie schmeckt sehr gut das ist so
ein genuss oder so köstlich eric muss
jetzt nach all diesen exzellenten vor
und hauptspeisen durften natürlich auch
kleine nachspeisen nicht fehlen die auch
alle für sich wahre highlights waren wie
zum beispiel ein eis am stiel welches
mit einer dampfenden präsentation an den
tisch gebracht wurden ein wassereis
unterscheiden was wir mit schoko oder
animationen eine blaubär nachspeise die
mein ganz persönliches highlight war die
wir glauben überhastet oder das ist so
lecker wieder schwer zu bauen das ist
mir egal ist so eine krasse cremigkeit
auch wieder welche sahne milch brücke
auch das je nach absolut 10 von 10 und
zu guter letzt eine variation aus
praline makarov schokokuchen und panna
cotta ich genieße das ganze jetzt wir
machen die kamera mal aus und wir sehen
uns im büro ein bisschen zeit hatte über
das reflektieren weil es war auf jeden
fall eins verrückt das einzige was ich
sagen kann ist dass sie samt bin und
dass wir es an überhaupt nichts gefehlt
hat ist das für was heißen das ist echt
nicht eindeutig gewesen für mich
zumindest zu beginn deshalb
und da sind wir wieder das war so ein
dreh bei dem ich meine mutter anrufen
und ihr davon erzählt weil ich wirklich
so krass finde was ich da erlebt habe
und meine mutter fand genauso kraft und
meinte ich muss diese begeisterung auch
im video wieder rüberbringen und ich
habe auch meinen freunden erzählt vater
hin er macht das erlebt dass und wie man
auch sicher dass man den namen rené
matur wahrscheinlich auch noch in 10 20
jahren kennen wird für diejenigen die es
interessiert wir haben 419 euro bezahlt
für zwei personen alkoholfreie
begleitungen und einfach an für einen
unvergesslichen abend deshalb sehr sehr
viel geld aber krass
bis zum nächsten mal